welcome to metaphysical milkshake I am
one of your hosts Reza Aslin
and I am the more important of the other
hosts Rayne Wilson hello I don't know if
I'd say more important I would say
perhaps a little more known maybe I
don't know I am more famous I am more
wealthy and I am taller yes those are
all true and grayer
and grayer you look you look positively
flushed right now though what uh I'm I'm
feeling very relaxed yeah I'm feeling uh
I'm feeling radiant right now have you
been drinking what's what's no I'm uh
I'm uh what they call Post coital oh
goodness gracious yeah yeah I'm posting
did you are you telling me you came to
this podcast right out of bed no I mean
we're you you know we're recording this
in the morning I had a zoom
at 10 and then I told my wife I would
meet her for some
intimacy time at 10 30 a.m wait was it
actually on the count you guys had to
schedule your uh it was on the I love
making we share the hike out it was on
the share nightcow welcome to
metaphysical Milkshake the show where we
go deep we get weird and we search for
the meaning of Life along the way
presented by cast media and soul pancake
[Music]
no it's it's terrible it's terrible when
you are middle aged and you've got a lot
of zooms and pitches and issues and
um raising a kid and you know it just
love making gets put so far on the back
burner if you don't schedule it it
doesn't happen dude you know when I was
when we were in our 20s and 30s and in
previous relationships it just kind of
like hey look let's get some pizza oh
look the baseball games on all of a
sudden you're [ __ ] and then you're
just going on a walk and then you're
watching the dog and then you you're
you're buying something at the drugstore
but
um it doesn't work that way in in
long-term married life so I um we have
taken to having to schedule sex and like
take out our little eye cows and and
look over the dates and you know make
sure we're clear it
you have to leave enough time because
that puts a lot of pressure because
sometimes I get there and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I have to like perform all of a
sudden and you know uh it doesn't quite
work that way for me at the tender age
of 56 so uh what about you guys what
about you guys how's that look I'm
making fun of you for you know having to
write on the on the calendar sex 10 30
a.m to 10 35 a.m I get that
um and it's and it's complicated but I
shouldn't make fun it was 10 it was 10
30 to 10 33 a.m 10 33 Okay
um but you know I shouldn't make fun of
you because I actually greatly admire
that because people don't realize you've
been married for a very long time I've
been married for like half the the years
that you've been married but still we've
been married for for a while now and and
I I think people forget that like
marriage takes work and practice like
you gotta actually be active about it
like this idea that you think that
shit's just gonna happen like you know
you're gonna be in the middle of getting
lunch ready for the for the kids and
then you're gonna like look at each
other with like lust in the eyes and
like right at that moment like that [ __ ]
doesn't happen like you need to actually
work a lot like the movies is work
people love is work love is work it's
hard work it's specific work it's
detailed work it's daily work I learned
this because I read a book about it tell
me about it by the gottmans oh the
Julian's and John gottman the very very
famous
relationships scientists the marriage
scientists that's exactly what they are
they've boiled all of this complicated
marriage stuff down to some really easy
to do fundamentals it's uh it's utterly
fantastic let's get them the hell on
this show like now they have so much we
need it right share folks if you're
unfamiliar with the gottmans uh they are
you know the the Godfathers of Love uh
therapy rain is absolutely right like
this is love science this isn't just
like wishy-washy you know like how to
how to you know have better sex in like
four days by like using whipped cream
and cherries and stuff these are
scientists who have done massive amounts
of scientifically rigorous studies on
why some people stay in love and some
people don't and in fact uh John
gottman's got this thing where he says
he only needs about 15 minutes with a
couple
about 15 minutes and he's done this for
40 years in 15 minutes he can tell you
with something like 90 accuracy whether
you two are going to work or not
it takes 15 minutes and unbelievable are
there are there electrodes involved
no but weirdly there is whipped cream
and cherries involved and uh by the way
Julie Schwartz gottman herself a PhD
also a relationship a guru and genius
and like these two are married which is
a conversation that we're going to have
to have with them to figure out exactly
yes definitely definitely together they
have authored I mean literally like
hundreds of books I'm not just like
exaggerating I think it is like in the
hundreds and their newest book is called
the love prescription and it's uh seven
days to more intimacy connection and joy
and you know we brought them here
because of two reasons number one uh
because you know we're interested about
this question like can you does love
last forever like is that a thing that
just only happens in movies or does like
it's is that possible is it possible is
it attainable well and then the second
thing is because uh my wife Jessica and
I actually went to a gottman Institute
uh that's right at their house what like
six months ago or something yeah it
wasn't that long ago it was like last it
was like maybe three months ago ever
since then I've been desperate to try to
be their friends
and I'm just hoping like if I invite
them on the podcast like you know
they'll want to be friends and stuff
yeah you're just trying to get free
therapy out of the deal well that too
that too Julie schwartzkottman PhD is
co-founder and president of the gottman
Institute and co-founder of effective
software she was honored with the 2021
Lifetime Achievement Award by the
Psychotherapy Network winner of
Washington state psychologist of the
year she has co-authored seven books
including 10 principles for doing
effective couples therapy baby makes
three and eight dates I mean their their
accolades go on and on John gottman was
voted one of the top 10 most influential
therapists of the past quarter Century
well professor emeritus in Psychology at
UW
um and you're right 200 published
academic articles of more than 45 books
including the best-selling seven
principles for making marriage work uh
they both run the gottman Institute
which is just fantastic this whole and
this whole idea they're gonna dig into
love is a practice More Than A Feeling
it's an action it's something you do
it's not something that happens to you
let's bring on board
the doctors gottman
John N Julie gottman thank you so much
for joining us on the milkshake this is
such a an honor for for both of us we've
both been reading your works for a
really long time you guys are you guys
the the the original the ogs right the
ogs of love can I call you guys the ogs
of love I don't think they know what
OG's stands for you either is that what
you mean no original gangsters original
gangsters
so I I've mentioned this on the podcast
a couple of times now so uh most of our
listeners know that uh Jessica and I
actually came to your house uh on Orcas
and did one of these big sort of weekend
Retreats and and uh I love the story
John of how you got started in this
field like you became an expert on love
if I'm not mistaken because you needed
help getting laid am I right about that
is that about right well it wasn't so
much uh needing help with uh with having
sex as it was with
um love lasting you know that those are
different things yeah yes tell us a
little bit about tell us a little about
how you got started if you don't mind
well
um my friend Bob Levinson and I uh
became friends at Indiana University and
uh we were commiserating with one
another about how every one of our
relationships with women had turned into
a disaster and then we decided to
collaborate with one another and we
actually you know did a test drive uh
collaborating with one another and we
had fun uh Bob was worried I might turn
into a lunatic
and you know and we decided to to build
a lab and uh combine his expert
knowledge of physiology uh and
electronics with my expert knowledge of
how to observe people
and we sort of did this initial study
together where we had 30 couples come
into the lab and just talk about how
their day went and talk about a major
conflict and a positive topic and then
we sent him home and you know
didn't help anybody we had no clue how
to help anybody at that time was it
until I met Julie who was a really
accomplished therapist that we started
actually trying to help people but we
re-contacted the couples three years
later and found that our measures of
physiology and the way they talk to one
another could predict with 90 accuracy
how the relationship had changed in the
subsequent three years
but that was kind that was pretty
remarkable and there wasn't any
psychological research that did anything
but account for about nine percent of
the variation we were accounting for
over 90 of the variation and it kind of
blew our minds were you good at numbers
how did you get into the statistics of
this yeah I started Life as a
mathematician I even went to MIT and got
a master's degree in math before I went
into psychology my roommate at MIT was a
psychology student and I found these
books more interesting than mine so like
yeah I could imagine psychology after
that that's fantastic I love mathematics
you do this work as a couple
um I'm fascinated by that how long have
you been together when did you meet and
and how do you deal with the pressure of
being a couple known for your expertise
in couple ship I mean you guys I'm so
sorry you can't get divorced
like all of the thousands of people
you've helped and and millions that have
read your books are going to be so
devastating
effect Mom Mom Dad don't get divorced
please but how did you how did you meet
um and what's that pressure like okay so
we met in a coffee shop we've been
together for 36 years married 35 years
um and he was really really cute and
really sexy so you know I knew we had no
trouble getting laid beforehand and
um we just started to talk uh over
coffee and of course this was in Seattle
the coffee capital of the universe and
we had a fabulous conversation and then
um we started having phone conversations
I went on a speaking tour uh and John
sent me flowers at every Hotel I stayed
in which blew my mind nobody had ever
given me flowers before
so it was fantastic so in we started
working together probably nine years
after we were married
um I was doing individual therapy with
really really really really really
difficult folks people who were addicts
who were suffering from addiction PTSD
combat veterans torture victims you know
all kinds of people who were really
really really in pain and John meanwhile
was coming home and telling me all of
his great research findings and I
couldn't resist I got sucked in to this
fabulous you know not a dark hole a
sunlit hole of fabulous uh information
and I just kept saying why don't we
share this with people you know why
should we just keep it in the Ivory
Tower so uh we formed an Institute The
gottman Institute with a dear friend and
and
um we were off and running and created
the theory together created the
interventions together uh the design of
the Workshops the design of the
trainings all that stuff we did together
and
um
you know at first it was really hard
because we were bridging two very
different worlds I was a very arrogant
scientist
and uh you know kept fighting Julie's uh
intuition until I eventually learned
that no I'm always right she really
knows what she's talking about
and uh and once we started really
collaborating uh it was it was magical
yeah and you know it has been ever since
so it's yeah there is pressure
um but you know pressure to do what well
pressure to help more people you know
our work together has been just man a
Magic Carpet Ride I can't believe how
many opportunities have come to us and
our relationship I mean you know
we knew at the very beginning that this
was going to be Rock Solid you know even
though we didn't know anything we didn't
know how to have a relationship either
one of us both of us had been divorced
before right so
um we knew nothing but the couples that
John studied and later I joined him in
some of that study taught us everything
of course so you know yeah we apply all
of that in our own relationship yes
constantly every day yeah let's not do
what those guys do yeah that's right
exactly yeah I could see that
right this is a true story did you know
that I didn't have like a primary doctor
until I was 49 years old like I wait
what yeah I mean you know like first of
all I'm an immigrant and immigrants we
don't go to the doctor anyway like your
arms got to be like hanging by you know
some sinews before like your mom says
all right let's go to the doctor
otherwise you just kind of rub some dirt
on it and you're fine and so as a grown
man it occurred to me suddenly oh my God
like I'm almost 50 years old almost half
a century old and I don't have a doctor
but I had no idea how to go about like
finding a primary care physician until I
heard about ZocDoc zoc doc yeah it's
this free app
it's kind of like you know it's like you
you have all these apps that tell give
you reviews about like where to go if
you want a good beer or where to go if
you want a good brunch well why not an
app that tells you who to go to if you
want a a good doctor that's what ZocDoc
is it shows you all the doctors they're
all patient reviewed they all take your
insurance and they're all available when
you need them find and review local
doctors read verified patient reviews
from real people who have made real
actual appointments so now when you walk
into that doctor's office you're all set
to see someone in your network who gets
you so go to zocdoc.com find the doctor
that is right for you and book an
appointment in person or remotely that
works for your schedule every month
millions of people use ZocDoc and I am
one of them America it's my go-to
whenever I need to find and book a
quality doctor so go to zocdoc.com
milkshake and download the ZocDoc app
for free
then start your search for a top-rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours that's zocdoc.com milkshake
zocdoc.com
milkshake this is what like your 200th
book have you have you lost count
because I've lost count like you've
written dozens and dozens of books on
the subject I think that's safe to say
and you've been doing this as you say
for decades and it got me to thinking I
wonder
she has like the meaning of Love
changed over the decades has it become
easier or harder uh you know how would
you how would you describe sort of the
current status of of the way that we
maybe this is important to keep it
culturally defined so let's just say in
America uh how have you seen the very
idea of love and marriage and
relationships change over the years and
actually interestingly Miranda and I
were just talking about this earlier how
has it changed during the pandemic
because rain and I were talking about
how we have all these friends who got
divorced as a result of the pandemic
whereas for rain and me it was the
opposite like we've never been closer to
our wives because of the past you know
two years stuck under the same roof
actually made us closer than ever so I'm
I'm just curious when you look at the
Decades of of working with marriages
working with love how is the how are
those two concepts changed and how has
the pandemic changed them even more no
it's interesting I'm reading a book uh
called wired for love
uh by a neuroscientist named cassiopa
who is married to a very famous
neuroscientist John cassiopa who
unfortunately died when they've only
been married seven years I believe and
she's she's uh really in this book talks
about how social neurosciences found
that love is universal that you know the
kinds of things that work and love
really are true across the whole planet
really and hold for the human brain you
know everywhere on the planet and that's
kind of what we discovered is that the
things that make a relationship
successful or doomed are the same
everywhere everywhere on the planet
they're the same and you mentioned the
pandemic and you know it's really true
that you know some people
really tanked during the pandemic the
relationships got worse and worse and
some people you know like us our
relationship got better and better over
the pandemic so it's absolutely true let
me add a few things you know I think uh
because we're so old we can talk
historically with real experience
you know in the old days before the
internet you know you met more in person
through friends through colleagues Etc
uh and you got to know each other and
there would be time before you went to
bed together
and uh there would be a bit of a
friendship more emotional connection and
so on uh in addition people didn't leave
each other quite so quickly you know no
mind you this was before women's
Liberation it was before women went back
to work and so on but these days in
comparison
God man it's such a different world in
that
um people are typically meeting over the
internet people are not necessarily
telling the truth on the internet and so
there's uh a lot of fantasy that's
happening over the Internet uh that may
not prove to be real and when people
finally meet up uh does it work or not
well they go to bed fast and before
they've really formed the emotional
safety that is needed in order to really
have a fulfilling love life passionate
life as well as a life together as mates
or partners so people are also leaving
each other much more quickly
um it's like okay you know partner
number one nah forget it and they're
more reluctant to marry the
um marital
age is getting older a little bit older
a little bit older especially every
decade and some of that has to do with
career some of that has to do with just
fear uh because they've seen their
parents divorce and they don't want to
take the same risks uh where there could
be a divorce the same things matter
around the globe but people don't know
about them
and they have substituted internet kind
of electronic connection
for uh face to face and it it creates
some challenges yeah yeah I I know from
my wife and I oftentimes an evening
relaxing is
watching a show on streaming television
and then going to the bedroom where I I
play uh chess on my phone and she reads
on her iPads so we go from big screen to
little screens and then lights out so
that has its challenges right but it's
interesting you're talking about divorce
and separation and uh res and I were
talking about this before the show
there's a there's I'm a member of the
Baha'i faith and there's a teaching in
the Baha'i faith about divorce and by
the way Baha'is are not any better at
marriage and divorce than anyone else we
have I think even a higher divorce rate
than most people there's a wonderful
teaching called a year of patience or a
year of waiting where if you if the
couple knows that they want to get a
divorce they're asked to separate live
separately not have sex engage minimally
other than counseling or dealing with
the children and what you need to deal
with and really like deeply spiritually
philosophically Ponder
um
you know their marriage their past what
they want their future kind of just
slows everything way way way way down
now I have a lot of Baha'i friends that
went through the year of patients and
still got a divorce but I have many that
still you know three months in seven
months in we're like you know let's give
this another trial that they absolutely
would not have done
um if they had kind of because I've seen
this a lot too contemporary couples kind
of a rush to divorce kind of like they
don't understand me that's it I'm done
and then it gets contentious very
quickly and uh you know best friends
become best Frenemies it's the giving up
thing you know any thoughts on on this
kind of transition from separation to
divorce well you know I think uh that
the Baha'i faith contains a lot of
wisdom and what you are expressing is
indeed uh very wise in that when people
are living together
uh and going through day-to-day life
together
they can either grow very very distant
from one another to the point where they
don't connect or very very conflicted
because they don't know how to have
conflict nobody takes relationships 101
in high school right when we really need
it and so what we see uh in both our
private practice and in our workshops
and so on are people who realize that
they really don't know how to love and
that's why we wrote this book because
people think it's a much bigger deal
it's much more complicated than it
really has to be loving each other is as
simple as saying how you doing honey how
was your day or saying God you look
gorgeous today or just you know the
small little moments of turning towards
our partners
little moments every single day and
that's what this book is about how you
can really change your relationship in
seven days by doing a small thing a
little differently each day yeah there
was a study done at UCLA by the Sloan
foundation in which they studied dual
career couples with young children and
you know in two careers and they put
cameras and microphones in the couple's
home and what they found is that most of
these marriages spent less than 10
percent of an evening in the same room
and they talk to each other an average
of 35 minutes a week what 35 minutes a
week and most of the talk was about
errands about the to-do list that the
couple had yeah so really these
relationships are getting ignored and
the couple is focusing on working the
children uh and not really doing things
that nourish the relationship and that's
where the trouble really begins wow well
you I would love to hear some of your
love prescriptions from the book
um and I loved this idea of small things
often I wrote that that's like that's
the thing that I write on everything now
just small things often Small Things
often like if you were gonna if you were
gonna like enrap this all into like
three words that would be it yeah that's
right isn't it funny because Small
Things often also applies to life like
life isn't big sweeping changes it's
kind of these little micro adjustments
you make along the way like I want to do
this a little bit better I want to work
out for five minutes I want to walk one
mile like you know what I mean like yeah
well that's kind of what we discovered
in the apartment lab that Julie and I
built and which we uh saw 130 newlywed
couples and followed them as many became
pregnant and had babies and we studied
them in interaction with their babies as
well and followed the babies as they got
older and it turned out these very small
moments where one person would try to
get their partner's attention or
interest in something and we the other
camera would focus on how did the
partner respond right and if they turn
toward this request for them for their
attention or interest then they stayed
married and the people who stayed
married had turned toward these requests
these bids the connection an average of
86 percent of the time and the couples
who eventually divorce when we looked
six years earlier they turned toward
their Partners bids only 33 percent of
the time so this huge difference between
just these small moments of connection
made a huge difference and even affected
conflict because the couples who turned
toward at that 86 percent level
had a sense of humor even when they
fought with one another they could laugh
together and reduce physiological
arousal this is what I really love about
your your work is that it's not that
complicated I mean I don't mean to you
know that's not meant to be as a slam or
anything but it's not that complicated
it's actually kind of easy you were
talking about the Turning towards thing
which is so basic and yet has such a
huge difference in a relationship and
just to to clarify what you were saying
for for our audience it's just a matter
of you know when one partner says
something like uh uh you know hey uh the
the there's an interesting Cloud uh
outside right the other person has three
options right you can either sort of
turn against it just be like clouds
you're looking at Clouds right now who
cares right or you can be sort of
neutral just like uh-huh yeah that's
nice nope not true yeah that one is
actually turning towards that that's all
it takes is uh-huh quality or you cannot
say a word
just ignore it and that's turning away
right every couple knows what we're
talking about right now every single
couple right knows exactly what we're
talking about what like the other person
says something like oh honey check this
out or whatever and you're like yeah let
me add let me add another one I think
that's really really important and we
talk about this in the book which is
saying thank you
expressing gratitude gratitude gratitude
and you know I mean that goes in
relationships but it's also an
individual State of Mind are you
noticing what's right in the world are
you noticing what your partner is doing
that you like or that you appreciate say
thank you so the unhappy couples
um it's been found in another study that
the unhappy couples would only notice 50
of what their Partners were doing right
right happy couples it was much closer
to 100 percent
so it's about noticing it's about
awareness and I think this really ties
in with the pandemic in that we felt so
burdened so oppressed by the
consequences of the pandemic that many
many many people got more depressed got
more anxious
just really felt horrible and what the
antidote was for that and still is as
well as in our relationships is look for
what's going right is there anything
going right
the fact that your partner is sitting
next to you even if you're just watching
TV how wonderful that they're sitting
next to you and you can cuddle you say
thank you or if your partner happened to
pour the coffee this morning you say
thank you if your partner saw that you
were tired and got up and did the dishes
wow huge thanks thank you thank you
so it's transformative I mean it sounds
simple like I do I do all the house
chores at my house I do all the cooking
and cleaning and laundry and all of that
stuff and it's just kind of how I was
sort of raised to do it and I've had
I've lived with a number of women and
there's and I've always done that job
and there's always been this weird sort
of bitterness towards it but my wife
Jessica says thank you to everything
that I do but just the thank you makes
all the different because you you feel
seen you feel acknowledged it's just a
simple thing like hey thank you for
making dinner uh it was delicious like I
will make you dinner every night after
that this is why this book is so great
again there's these tiny things Reach
Out And Touch someone you know give
compliments the list goes on and on but
Reza I thought we could try one of these
exercises right now because let's do it
it says in the book what are Masters Of
Love
best at doing and they're best at what
they're great at is holding in the front
of their minds what they admire most
about their chosen person so you and I
having done a hundred podcasts together
working together for three years I'd
like you to begin then I'll go what is
it that you hold in the front of your
mind that you admire most about me and
our little podcast marriage okay here it
goes here it goes I think that the thing
that I admire most about rain Wilson
after years and years of of our podcast
uh friendship
is how serious of a person he actually
is you know I I say this all the time I
think people would be very surprised
when they meet you know the person Rayne
Wilson because they're familiar with the
actor Rayne Wilson and the actor Rayne
Wilson is often a goofball right but the
person Rayne Wilson is a very serious
sophisticated intellectual spiritual
person and I think it surprises people
you know people are people are like a
little bit taken back they just assume
that you're just some sort of doofus
in in real life when in reality you're
you're you're nothing of the sort very
well thought very you know a real deep
deep thinker and also as you know
because we've had this conversation a
million times I don't have any respect
for people who don't put their values
into practice or their faith into
practice like if you're not doing it
then what's the point
of believing it and uh and you're you're
somebody who is is adamant about doing
it
oh wow that's really beautiful Reza
thank you so much that's really that
really means a lot truthfully thank you
so much so my next question wait a
minute wait wait hold on hold on did you
did you forget something did you no I
was saying that because part of what's
really interesting here is they have a
section about ask a big question and
that's really what we do on this I
appreciate that I appreciate that I
thought I'd at least I thought you were
gonna say my butt I thought at the very
least you were gonna appreciate myself I
can't I can't top you on that I can't
type that was very well said and so well
formulated it really truly means a lot I
will say that what I love about you Reza
is that you are engaged you are fiercely
deeply engaged in the act of living a
life I mean it's whether it's being a
dad and raising kids whether it's being
married and like deepening your marriage
whether it's engaging politically
whether it's philosophically writing
books in kind of like sharing ideas like
you you never phone it in you're always
a hundred percent you're deeply deeply
curious and I think the world could use
a lot more people like you yeah I love
you rain oh I love you too Rose I really
do but going back to this now speaking
one of the things we do in our podcast
is we ask a big we ask life's big
questions that's part of the inspiration
for this podcast is digging into life's
big and you talk a lot about that as a
tool tell us about how which is
interesting because our podcast could
actually be a marital Aid Reza
um but talk about how why what's the
importance of asking big questions not
little question how was your day is one
thing but like what do you want out of
life is like one that you you put in
here why the big questions here's why
because as human beings we all are
philosophy visitors every single person
no matter what your education no matter
what your IQ none of that stuff matters
it's really that here we land on this
Earth and
all of us are asking at a deep level
what do what's my purpose why do I want
to live why do I want to live I mean
it's an interesting question yeah I've
got a self-preservation Instinct but
what else what do I want to give what do
I want to contribute
it's part of Victor Frankel's work who
is a concentration camp Survivor and who
wrote about people's search for meaning
we look for meaning human beings are
meaning makers and so one of the most
important things you know in our little
brains is how do we make sense of what's
happening around us how do we create an
internal world that has our values our
priorities our ethics our moral
principles and our dreams
who do we want to be
so it's really important to share and
ask those questions in a relationship
because when you're talking about those
bigger questions
it opens up each person's core it opens
up each person's heart way down solely
into
the very center of their being and when
you share that with your partner here's
a real connection yeah absolutely yeah
Shakespeare said we are the stuff that
dreams are made of
and it's so essential to who we are as
human beings yeah
that we ask those questions about
what is it our life going to mean and
what does it mean that we've lived and
what does it mean that we're going to
die
and couples who really do that together
who not only have a relationship but
create a life together that has purpose
and meaning
really wind up having much more
joy in their lives much more intimacy
and connection you know on metaphysical
milkshake we try and reach for the
biggest possible questions and and I was
thinking like putting aside all the
prescriptive
um uh Little Gems of this book and and
of your work what you've discovered in
the lab what you've discovered through
statistics uh we haven't even mentioned
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
resume maybe you can sum those up when
we're when we're wrapping this up but
putting all that aside one question I
had for you is kind of taking off your
therapist hats and putting on your kind
of just
philosophical human
hats your your Victor Frankl hats by
studying marriages for all of these
years
what have you learned about us human
beings what what if you could boil it
down to just like what does it mean to
be a human being what have you what have
you then learned about
human society and what human society
needs to be or to Aspire toward from
your work our future and where we're
headed but I was just interested in the
I'm sure by observing 20 000 marriages
and writing about them you can distill
it down into like
who are we what do we need and where are
we going mm-hmm
so you know I think what
I already guessed but I have learned
over and over and over again is how much
we need each other
and that we are terrified of saying how
much we need each other you know that's
something that is really oh gosh so
messed up in our own culture in America
people think they have to pull
themselves up by their bootstraps that
if something goes wrong in their life
and they end up on the street it's their
fault we blame them instead of our
systems
uh that
you're not supposed to need anybody
you're supposed to be an individual and
autonomous and blah blah blah well that
is yes basically we are pack animals
we don't survive without
interdependency depending on one another
uh and part of that is relationships
with love also friendships also
connecting with our children we are
connectors we need each other and needs
are good they are not bad so about
humans you know what I would hope for
in the future
oh God is that
altruism grows
that we begin to
um see how much we actually do need each
other how good Terror feels how good it
feels to give care not just receive it
but to give it
uh and that we do a whole lot more of
that in the future not only for people
but for life that we give back to the
Earth we give back to the forest we give
back to the scene we give back to our
fellow creatures to legged or
four-legged
that our altruism wins the human War
between aggression and altruism
which were caught up in now
I know we're out almost out of time just
one last question here
um we were reading this Vice study uh
that was done in the UK and it said that
the average relationship this including
marriage regardless of marriage
um that the average relationship lasts
for two years and nine months which was
so depressing though also weirdly right
on target for my average before my
marriage like I think two years nine
months was basically every one of my
relationships until I got I got married
but it begs the question
is it possible to be in love forever is
love forever it's a very interesting
question it's an empirical question and
a lot of people have argued that you
can't be in love forever it wears you
out you know you have to go to being
loving one another but not being in love
but Helen Fisher has actually studied
this in the laboratory and looked at
what happens to the human brain when
you're in love
and you know and it's a remarkable thing
that happens and you just become better
at creative problem solving and all
kinds of things when you're in love it
really has a very very big effect on the
brain and it appears to have no shelf
life you can stay in love forever and
that's pretty amazing and and the
question becomes how do you manage that
how do you do that and that's kind of
what we're about is how do you stand
there forever but you really can be in
love forever I'm as much in love with
Julie now as I was the weekend that I
met her which was a miraculous weekend
that's how I feel about you Rayne oh oh
come on Rez up
yeah you know I think I would agree John
that uh depends you know there's so many
questions about how you define love and
in love typically means you're in the
soup of your own hormones right uh
chemistry is bubbling
um
however I guess I Define it differently
um I Define being in love as having a
million things to admire in your partner
to love about them to savor to enjoy
um
to
God you know never
imagine
somebody that could suit you better that
would feel better to you
they are the one they are the life
Journey for you
um and yeah I totally believe along with
the science that being in love forever
is absolutely possible yeah yeah well
um the book is profound all of your
books are profound uh I will definitely
check out that app you've got
um and just thank you so much for
um just Illuminating the the world of
of marriage and and sustaining long-term
love I mean it's uh when I first heard
about your Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse of marriage which are by the
way contempt defensiveness criticism and
stonewalling
um that was really brilliant because
when my marriage and it has several
times been in a really bad place those
four horsemen were definitely rearing
their ugly heads but you've brought so
much light to the world through your
work
um we're privileged to have had this
conversation with you and thank you so
much for being on the milkshake
and rain and Reza thank you so much for
the opportunity to share with your
audience you guys are doing great work
thank the quick little relationship
therapy between us too that was really
yes yes we've worked out so much some
things there the love prescription the
book is called seven days to more
intimacy connection enjoy John and Julie
gottman this has been an absolute
pleasure thank you you guys
uh incredible conversation Reza do you
feel like you got some practical tools
coming out of that conversation
different than the ones you got from uh
going to do a weekend with them well I
feel like that's an unfair question
because I'm already a master of love oh
and so yeah there's only so much that I
could learn but I feel like other people
probably uh have learned a lot from uh
the gottmans but here's what I would say
here's okay if you're one of these
people like me until very recently like
if you said relationship book to me I'd
be like go [ __ ] yourself I'm not gonna
read a relationship
what I will say is this
the Simplicity of it that we've talked
about this before like the little the
little bits of advice like again Small
Things often just like every day say I
love you to your wife or in the middle
of nothing you know just like grab your
partner uh and just give them a romantic
kiss for no reason like in the [ __ ]
grocery store just just do it it's like
these small things often make the
biggest difference or the other thing
that we talked about which was um this
whole like turning towards try that next
time next time your partner is like oh
my God this is like the funniest raccoon
on Instagram here stop what you're doing
even though you could not give a [ __ ]
about the raccoons right you could be in
the middle of Performing heart surgery
just stop
and say oh really let me see you know do
you know how um on uh the Terminator the
original one like he has like the
choices that come up on his screen yeah
like it's like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
he goes through the options and like yes
sometimes I'm so bad at inner human
interpersonal relationships that
sometimes I feel like the Terminator
where those options come up and and my
wife will be like look at the cute
raccoon on Instagram and I'll be like
leave me alone [ __ ] off I'm not
interested
oh I'd love to see and I'll go beep beep
beep beep beep oh I'd love to see I have
zero like actual impulse to see the
raccoon but I know it's the best thing
right it's the best choice ultimately
edits so easy and yet like so revelatory
I mean these guys they've they've
monitored they mentioned this a little
bit earlier and like if you thought that
it was weird it is weird but like they
actually have these apartments with like
cameras and recording devices that they
that they like pay couples to just live
in for a while so they could monitor
them which sounds like my [ __ ]
nightmare by the way but over and beyond
that they have all these stats and they
will tell you that the biggest
difference like the biggest indicator of
whether this is going to work or not is
if one person says hey check this out
and the other person stops and checks it
out whether they actually give a [ __ ] or
not
like yeah that little thing
can
dramatically
improve your love life so you know like
there's a lot of good stuff one of the
things that really struck me was when
she was talking about gratitude we've
because we've talked a lot about
gratitude and certainly in happiness
studies gratitude is a big part of that
sure you know daily expression of
gratitude and and whatnot
um but the whole idea that okay
expressing gratitude uh is important it
makes you happier and it makes you more
successful and increases your health and
stuff like that but
turning that gratitude toward your
partner is not something people talk
about a lot they talk about I'm grateful
for this cup of coffee I'm grateful that
I'm healthy today I'm grateful for the
sunshine but like you know to express it
to your partner I'm grateful for you I'm
I'm grateful for the way that you folded
the socks I'm I'm grateful for the way
that you made dinner I mean that's
that's crazy that's really
um I just I find that really um
uh is that I find it really is your
alarm going off
oh sorry we're in the middle of a
podcast right sorry what is that what do
you get to take medicine or something uh
no I've we've just I've got something
scheduled on the calendar
um with holiday uh right now so I gotta
run wait wait wait wait are you are you
about to go have more sex
we um
we just got we just have to uh we have
to connect about something so I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to run folks thanks folks
before thanks for having me yeah we
gotta wrap this up uh so that uh rain
can go and take care of things if you
know what I mean uh if you want more of
life's big questions uh it's very easy
all you got to do is find us on social
media at Reza Aslin at Rayne Wilson
we're on Twitter at metamilk podcast on
Instagram at metaphysical milkshake let
us know your last big questions we might
just explore them on a future episode
and remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on Apple podcast
wherever else you listen to podcasts and
in fact if you review metaphysical
milkshake on Apple podcasts all you
gotta do is send us a screenshot of that
review to Medicine
that is not the nice day screenshot I
said I think yeah I'm just backing you
up I'm like screenshot are we oh okay
all right I thought maybe we're I'm
being supportive I'm being see I've got
your back I'm I'm here this is good
couple ship send the screenshot to
metaphysical at castmedia.com that's
cast with a K and we will send the first
five people who do that we will send you
a copy of the gottman's new book The
Love prescription and let me tell you
you you probably need it so if you want
this is a prescription you need
all you gotta do put down those opioids
America
this is your prescription and you can
obviously subscribe to the metaphysical
milkshake YouTube channel and watch our
full episodes every week rate rain are
you are you still here are you still
here I'm I'm here but I really gotta go
I'm gonna I'm gonna be in the doghouse
so I gotta go thanks everyone for tuning
in we'll see you next week metaphysical
milkshake
we love you keep that love flowing a
Love Supreme
bye bye-bye metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rain Wilson Reza
Aslan and Colin Thompson it is produced
by Safa samasade yazt Harris Lane Mick
damaria Hashem South and DJ lubel cast
media is the production and distribution
partner original music by Jeff Tang
[Music]
and it it sounds simple but I swear to
God I will gladly do every dish in this
house now simply because will you marry
me
hahaha
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you